what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation this day is turning out to
be more eventful than d23 itself John
how are you I am super excited how are
you sir super excited the Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 official trailer has
arrived if you haven't seen our reaction
to the holiday special that's up here on
this channel also please leave a like
thirdly thank you to all who have shown
your support by checking out our merch
at shopzeroedition.com get beatings like
this to show your member of the reject
Nation citizen King exclusive we got all
kinds of cool things over there anywho
it's a good Christmas present that's
what I'll say to us
[Music]
we were gone for quite a while oh wow
new suits
no matter what happens next
Galaxy still needs its Guardians that's
an upgrade yeah we come in peace
seriously dude
oh
hey dodgeball
don't forget
[Music]
baby rocking
like the gorillas
our whole lives
whoa Pete I'm done running
I'll rock it
there is
there yeah
damn we'll all fly away together
oh one last time
[Music]
oh dang oh it doesn't stop
we are Groot
we are Groot
that is so much more emotional that I
was expecting
don't kill anyone who gets in our way no
not kill anyone kill a few people kill
no people kill one guy one stupid guy
who no one loves now you're just making
it sad
wow especially after getting that
holiday special the last time we checked
in with the Guardians to be getting a
trailer like that which just looks
insanely heavy oh yeah and full of all
kinds of emotional weight throughout I
mean it really looks like it's gonna be
Rockets movie though I mean even in this
trailer as much as we're cutting around
and everyone as excited as it is to get
you know Adam Warlock into the phrase
exciting as it is to get high
evolutionary into the mix which
obviously is going to be tied into
Rocket Raccoon story man Rocket's just
like like would they have that one image
there of quill just like looking over
something and screaming it looked like
he was in the lab and I'm like is that
Rocket's body that he's like letting out
that painful anguish yell at you know
yeah this looks like it's going to be
very painful and you know obviously
haven't seen the holiday special slight
spoilers here they've revealed that
mantis and and Peter Quill are indeed
siblings actually both
um children of ego getting that kind of
family thread tying into here as well
and then the Guardians means so much
about abandon Misfits who are like
family and then this heartbreak like
this just looks so emotional and
ethereal that other flavor of James gun
like if you hop into like a show of
James Gunn first few episodes of the
Season would be like Guardians volume
one and two and this would be like the
final stretch yeah it feels that way you
know like oh this one gets like really
serious right now yeah absolutely and I
I'm really excited to see what that
makes of the tone and I think it's no
secret that you and I didn't absolutely
love the more sort of comedic and
boisterous qualities that the second
movie had but I feel like this is really
cool because it incorporates obviously
the humor that we know and love from the
guardians but it does look so much more
sort of impactful and affecting and like
it's going to be a finite you know
ending of at least this chapter in what
the Guardians of the Galaxy means to the
MCU and you had to see so many moments
especially like I almost wonder if the
high evolutionary is using some element
of Peter's you know Celestial DNA to you
know do some kind of horrific experiment
or whatever it might be but you really
get this sense that sacrifices will be
made there will be loss and the family
I'm mean that he said like this is the
last time we will see this Guardians
team together this way and I believe
that you know like you get that sense
even off of this trailer and I think
that's really a beautiful opportunity
for James Gunn to come back and to
perhaps put his definitive stamp it's
like he helped reinvent you know what
the MCU could be with the first movie A
lot of people love the spirit of the
second movie but this looks like it can
make a huge impact and really showcase
James Gunn's more mature and more
dramatic filmmaking chops as well
because you know family is a convergence
of warmth and humor and and you know
spirits but also you know it's it's hard
and there are times where families are
tested and I feel like that's absolutely
what this is going to be I think they're
gonna have to be bringing back some
things from the first couple of gardens
movies I imagine that with Aisha at the
end of Guardians post-credits scene of
part two tied into Adam Warlock in some
way since she's the one who introduced
him the high evolutionary the little
glimpses we got this dude does look
Sinister and even though he had like a
funny Comic-Con entrance sorry you got
to show up in costume and stuff he does
look Sinister and I mean they all look
like they're going through just hell in
this trailer because even though Drax is
like funny and stuff there are moments
here where he it's just the Peril and
the pain just seems so present also with
Gamora this Gamora you know like where
does she belong and she's obviously
going to be linking up with them will
her and Peter fall in love like this
feels like there's gonna be so many
heartbreaking elements to it also or
perhaps a sense of melancholic Unity by
the end yeah which is like the main
flavor yet you might want out of a film
like this you know absolutely but the
space sequences also just look beautiful
there are parts of it that remind me of
what I've heard about 2001 A Space
Odyssey yeah and also a little bit of JJ
from Star Trek in a way sure yeah and I
love that you also have that aspect of
James Gunn's you know Vision on display
this very colorful very much like a
cartoon or a comic but it literally
there is a recent gorillas music video
where they are all like on the moon and
get those different colored spacesuits
and it looks almost exactly like that to
me but I love that that even with this
heavier installment we're still getting
these really imaginative new looking you
know colorful popping visuals yeah and
it's cool you know if the holiday
special didn't come out I wouldn't be as
excited for every little moment I've
seen a mantis yeah it's kind of crazy
like that the holiday special really did
something for me when it comes to mantis
so every time I see something special or
like her little emotional beats that you
see of her in this trailer actually hit
that much more because of the fact that
she was the main character in the
holiday special and we got to really
understand her with that much more depth
everything about this trailer was really
cool and said I was surprised by it and
of course the we are Groot him and Peter
firing the guns together the action's
probably gonna be James Gunn's best out
of this Trilogy easily I wonder how much
you're gonna let him let loose with
going all out because damn this like you
just skim this if you just skim this
without music you just or audio these
visuals uh they hit on a whole different
kind of level because they really do
serious ass [ __ ] you know yeah and
that's kind of what I'm getting at here
is this I I I'm not I wasn't prepared
for that but yeah and also new space
creatures and stuff like that but uh
here we are Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3. it all comes to a close here guys
what did you think about this trailer
please leave your thoughts down below
and uh listens for the pain
flat door and buddy I know that uh Black
Panther wakanda forever did not quite
hit the mark for you in the way you were
hoping but this trailer shows me that
this could do something special I hope
this one delivers for you dude the flip
trailer regardless flev I want to say
thank you for all the sweet things
you've been saying to us throughout the
months especially I made a post on
patreon last month where you said some
of the kindest things ever so those
things are really take to heart and you
are part of the reject Nation family in
every single way so dude I hope you have
an amazing Christmas a happy holidays
and you know make some awesome 2023
resolutions because you've got some
goals to accomplish and we have faith
that with someone with a spirit like
yours you're able to do it dudes love
you fluffy flop fluffle
[Music]